a brand new month is approaching and
that means it's the perfect time
to let go you can play the 30-day
minimalism game and also
download our free printable 30-day
minimalism game calendar
over at theminimalists.com game
enjoy minimalists
with youth having unprecedented access
to porn over the past 20 years i'm
wondering what the impact has been
on these now young adults well they
experience trauma similar to someone who
has experienced
sexual abuse let's talk about porn we
talked about porn of yesteryear we know
about the porn of today
and it's you know it it's unlimited
and everything that you could want to
possibly search for you can make up for
not
know that you wanted to ever happen yeah
yeah
you could even make up something you've
never even seen i bet you you can find
something
uh some sort of video that that captures
that
that fake king what does porn of the
future
look like well to answer this quickly
and touch on that
i do think it's not the same as as a
person who's gone through sexual abuse
but look at tim's email from the
beginning um
he felt that something was taken from
him he felt that he had a tougher time
with his own sexual exploration i think
the statistic that the gen xers are
having less sex than any generation
before them
is the proof that porn and the
accessibility to porn
is having an impact on a generation
so are we worried about the population
because some people say oh well there's
less teen pregnancy the population
is going to go down no we're worried
about intimacy because intimacy
brings kindness brings empathy it brings
love which brings better things right
so i do think we're going to see more
and more numbers
of these types of people growing apart
and not having that intimacy which is
where we're scarred
porn of the future that's going to be an
interesting
uh thing because what happens is there's
men
or women that work in an office that
delegate the script writing
the scenarios and what is needed now i
personally believe those people should
be
white washed out every two years and new
fresh minds should come in because when
i've seen people sit there for 10 15
years
what happens is they bring things to us
that even we
are not ready for like so what it shows
me is they're completely burned out from
everything they've already produced
and they need to keep pushing the
envelope and pushing the envelope and
pushing the envelope and the performers
are
going like i don't want to do this like
this isn't something that
turns me on this isn't something i want
to promote you know a lot of women will
tell you there's scenes i was asked to
do
that i didn't want to do because i don't
think it should be out there yeah
you know whether it's rape style scenes
whether it's incestual
you know insinuated and sexual scenes
what is up with that by the way
that is those people i'm telling you
that need to leave those offices and
stop writing scripts
that are just just churning out this
stuff that i would say like you need new
writers
you need new people and i always also
you know i've gotten to travel to
different places to go into these
writers room and i'm like first of all
most of these writers aren't having any
sex
so that the wrong people be writing
right and then the ones
that have been doing it for too long or
just like nothing works for them anymore
you know what i mean and so then they're
like well let's bring the stepmom in and
the neighbor and
and the girl that looks like she's
definitely not 18 yet let's put her in
pigtails and high socks so we could push
and you read through these details
you're like that's it's those people
creating the content those are the
creators
that bring the ideas that then say we're
gonna do this this is a role you're
playing
that's why the only fan thing really
popped off the way it did was because
more women said
i've been in this long enough where i've
been asked to do way too many things
that i'm not comfortable with so i'll
just shoot my own content yeah
right so nobody these a lot of these
women are step moms
they don't want to play a step bomb in a
movie they don't want to do that
incestual thing that bothers them that
worry makes them worry about society
why are we promoting something that we
should not be promoting that's those
people and i think
i'm worried about the porn in the future
because we don't bring in fresh minds
or young people what do you want to see
why are these older men that have seen
everything why don't we bring in some 18
year olds and say
if you could direct a porno what would
you write how would it go down where
were they meets what would the scenario
be like you know yeah
i'd be intrigued to know what their
details would be yeah it's almost
yeah i see what you're saying about the
fear of porn of the future because
with all the incestual stuff out there
it's like
the bar just keeps getting raised and
now there's video games that they're
starting to build and launch where
a kid will be able to go on be like i
want this girl i want to do anal with
that guy
i want her to have a big butt so i can
make her butt bigger you know and they
can
make this girl and then this virtual
girl can do whatever they want they're
never going to leave the room
right and i think i think that's the the
problem when we
you know i think it could bifurcate a
few ways here when you go to virtual
reality sort of porn
um it's one step away from having you
know the
sex android in your house right there's
in it the problem with that is it apes
the form of intimacy
it makes you feel in the moment as
though it's a replacement or
a supplement for intimacy nothing wrong
with supplements but when your entire
diet
is a supplement you actually don't get
all the
the nutrients you need right yeah it's
not
natural literally and so while we can
supplement with
pornography when it when it takes place
of the intimacy and by the way it gets
better and better as technology improves
i see that as a potential problem where
i see a potential upside
is us being able to have conversations
like this with someone like lisa ann
who can talk about the the the good and
the bad the nuance
within it and also talk about intimacy
because you know you may know lisa anne
from
porn films that she's shot but you you
may not know
her feelings about intimacy and so be
able to have conversations about this
say
well ultimately sex has to do with
intimacy more than it has to do with
mere pleasure